[Music]
foreign
you're watching the Press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
pages of tomorrow's papers and checking
out the headlines with me tonight the
journalist and broadcaster Leslie
Riddick and also the writer Benedict
Spence great to see you both will chat
in a moment after we've taken a look at
those front pages for you starting on
the financial times reporting that Liz
truss and her government are poised to
reverse many of the key decisions
announced in the recent mini budget
the guardian's front page also reports
on a possible mini budget you turn as
Liz truss is said to have bowed to
intense pressure from Tory MPS
while the eye implies the timing is
deliberate with the chancellor quasi
quateng attending a meeting of the
international monetary Fund in
Washington
here's tomorrow's Daily Telegraph
leading with the Chancellor's vow to
fight on insisting he is not going
anywhere while the star compares the
prime minister to a wet lettuce leaf
will explain why later with the headline
I am evil I did this the Metro reports
on the trial of nurse Lucy leppy who's
accused of killing newborns in her care
on the sun's front page the referee
who's awarded maradona's Infamous hand
of Gog goal is reportedly trying to sell
the match ball for as much as three
million pounds and a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you can see on
screen join the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us discussing them and
I'm joined tonight by Leslie Riddick and
Benedict Spence great to see you uh this
evening thank you for joining us well
all the front pages pretty much have a
theme uh don't they
um let's have a look first of all at the
financial times a very important day
tomorrow of course uh Leslie um what do
you make of uh what's going on right now
it's quite extraordinary isn't it and
the language there from the Ft I mean
this isn't just to abandon or or put
aside this is ripping up the tax cut
package even that headline tells you
what actually you can read within the Ft
in its opinion columns that there's
really no way of ducking responsibility
for this no way of trying to kind of
pass it off to anyone else I see earlier
you had comments from Ken Clark talking
about it not being possible to for Liz
truss to scapegoat uh quasi kartangers
being responsible for all of this so it
really feels as if there's been a
political fiscal economic meltdown
coming together to just place the the
current policy and you'd think then The
credibility of the government completely
um in tatters tonight
uh Benedict The credibility in tatters
if as widely expected we're going to see
uh some u-turns uh what are you hearing
what's your analysis
oh it's pretty spectacular quite how
badly it's all gone you know a lot of
people were saying that Liz trust was uh
you know a candidate who divided opinion
as to whether or not she would be sort
of a bold brand new sort of Iron Lady or
whether she would be a disaster and it's
not taken too long for us to find out
what most of the markets think and
indeed what most of our own MPS think I
think actually the key thing on the
front page of financial times is a
desperate bid to save Premiership yeah I
mean what 37 38 days into this
Premiership and it's already on the
ropes and you know we all know of course
that we Face uh you know quite severe
financial situation in this country we
do across most of the world it's not
just limited to this country and that is
in part due to the coronavirus
coronavirus pandemic uh the war in
Ukraine many other factors but you know
she is you know thrown a match into this
Tinderbox ultimately and you know I I
think it sort of speaks ultimately to
the weakness within the conservative
party that there isn't even the
wherewithal actually to sort of back
this candidate who most of them didn't
want to be prime minister anyway you
know that whatever sort of spine there
is gone there is a realization that the
you know the top brass of the Tory party
has been hollowed out and if the
question now is one about saving the
Premiership well as bad a situation is
as it as she's found herself in
ultimately you turning on her sort of
her Banner headline policies that is a
recipe for disaster that is a prime
minister who is not wrong for this world
can she save her Premiership I don't
think that she can you know if she
presses ahead but I certainly don't
think she can if she decides to gut her
own mini budget yeah and the guardian
sums it up very well uh doesn't it trust
prepares new Mini budget U-turn in
latest blow to Authority uh and Leslie
um Benedict sort of hits a nail on the
head there I mean if if she u-turns uh
and is seen as weak how does she carry
on running the country for the next two
years I mean she's damned if she does
U-turn and she's damned if she doesn't
well well that's true but I mean I just
wonder when we're going to get to the
point that uh people feel that they they
don't want to see uh 170 000 Tory
members being potentially asked again to
decide or just the the notori MPS who
will take over here uh they don't want
to see probably just another concoction
of those folk who lost the last time
suddenly being good enough to run the
country I mean we need a general
election that the the Prime Minister
should apologize reverse the tax cuts
and resign and the fact that that's not
finding its way into front pages yet
seems quite astonishing to me but I'll
bet you it's going to start Gathering
next week Leslie do you think part of
the problem is that she she punished all
those members of the of of the of the
government who were back in which he
soon actually she sacked them and now
you've got the likes of Grant shaps and
uh uh uh Michael Gove uh sort of
plotting from the sidelines um
in a way that was one of one of the big
mistakes she made wasn't it that she
wasn't trying to unify the party she did
she had the opposite effect
well that's true but I think we've now
moved Beyond you know the sort of
bruised feelings of uh of people who had
been marginalized within the whole
election process this is now quite an
emergency and for for all the kind of
game playing and they perhaps Rye
Amusement that some people who didn't
vote Tori and didn't backlas trust now
feel watching the level of trouble that
she's got herself into she's got this
country into a total meltdown and
there's pensions and mortgages and
people's futures all sorts of stuff is
now hanging on on how she manages to
salvage her leadership whereas at the
same time I think people quite rightly
it's strange the markets have got this
one right you can't paste on credibility
now it needs a fresh start okay let's
talk about uh quasi quad saying uh
Benedict front page of the eye
um PM plans tax cut you turn while Kwa
Teng is out of the country he is in
America as we know interesting hearing
from our Deputy police go into Sam
Coates who was saying that even this
evening on the treasury Twitter feed
loads of photos of Quasi quateng the
message seemingly being that he's not in
a rush to come back to the UK on what is
going to be a huge day for the economy
yeah I can entirely understand why he
wouldn't be in a huge rush because he
doesn't want to carry the can for this
and I mean it's very clear that you know
the efforts are being made to sort of
tar him with the brush that ultimately
he's responsible and that this is a that
this is all he's doing but I don't think
that that's going to fly I think that if
he goes down the Prime Minister
absolutely goes down with him and I
think it would be very desperate
therefore to try uh to to to to to pass
off a lot of the responsibility for this
onto him ultimately they are wedded
ideologically in the same way
um but of course you can understand why
Liz truss will be wanting to pass the
blame on to him but equally why he
doesn't want to necessarily uh step into
the Limelight at the exact moment that
the U-turn has come he was the man that
delivered at the dispatch box the news
that so rattled the markets um I I can
completely understand for his own
personal reasons his own political
ambition why he wouldn't therefore want
to put himself back into the firing line
on behalf of somebody who ultimately
let's be very clear he's trying to throw
him under the bus
uh yeah similar theme uh Leslie on the
front of the telegraph quartet insists
I'm not going anywhere but there is a a
rebellious mood isn't there is a as you
you hinted at earlier I know when we
haven't got the times uh in front of us
but we'll talk about that next hour I'm
sure
um uh maybe a soon act more than modern
ticket others perhaps uh see themselves
in a role as well
um what do you make of all those
Rumblings from the back benches
well not surprising but quite seemingly
quite unprecedented I mean when you
start you just can't get past the
superlatives now around the the levels
of of kind of vitriol that are being
um being communicated quite openly uh to
all sorts of political correspondence
although as as the trust supporters will
point out all of them anonymously so uh
you know really really swinging things
being said about uh about the government
now and all sorts of former advisors uh
people that used to be closed list
truss's former advisor everyone now
being wheeled out and they were all wise
now that this was a terrible idea it
does leave you speechless as to how
we've gone through this whole process
over the summer to arrive at really the
quickest dud of a prime minister that
this country has recently had
uh let's finish with a look at the Daily
Star then uh their headline most urgent
political question of the year which wet
lettuce will last longer book is
offering odds of uh six to one uh
Benedict that are lettuce The Daily Star
bought from Tesco for 60p well Outlast
Liz truss as prime minister
well that's delightful isn't it
outlasting what sense are they very
hungry in the Daily Star offices or
somebody's going to start munching on it
I mean I understand the the joke
obviously but I mean yeah as it's just
being said there you know we're hearing
all sort of the sniping from the back
benches and you know Anonymous briefings
as to who it might be who might come
next who might replace Liz truss of
course hovering behind all of this is
the Dreadful Wicked Spectra of Boris
Johnson who you know yeah I know that
this might sound bizarre to a lot of
people but you know given how bad things
were under the Johnson Administration
but I think an awful Auditorium beers
will be looking at those days and
thinking my word did we make the right
decision given how
his trials uh yeah Leslie I mean there
is even talk about potentially bringing
back Theresa May or bringing back Boris
Johnson I mean we're in a situation at
the moment where nobody nobody can
predict what's around the corner
[ __ ] quite
um I mean I think if either of those
eventualities come to pass uh the next
the Supreme Court's been sitting most of
this week to look at whether the
Scottish Parliament uh is able to hold a
lawful Independence referendum you can
bet your bottom dollar that either of
those outcomes will stiffen resistance
to the Union in Scotland so you can't
just start to shuffle the the kind of
deck chairs on the Titanic British
democracy needs to regain some sense of
credibility and not just keep shifting
characters here there's a wholesale
reset needed for an Outlook that's
consistent that the markets believe that
looks like it's credible that people can
buy into and it's not anything that's
going to be produced by the characters
you've just mentioned yeah I mean even
the head of the rnf I'm giving a not
very disguised rebuke to uh the the
chancellor today okay thank you both for
the moment stay where you are plenty
more still to come including the UK and
France appear to be at loggerheads over
whether a nuclear strike on Rush shirt
should remain an option at discussing
that and more after this short break
[Music]
part two of The Press preview with me
now Leslie Riddick and Benedict Spence
there they are looking at the front page
of the Daily Telegraph Benedict uh UK re
Brooks rebukes macron for ruling out
Russia nuclear strike because we know
don't we that the UK the US NATO as well
have all been fairly ambiguous when it
comes to uh what response they might use
if uh Putin does decide to take the
nuclear option I mean the problem is
that diplomacy in language is so
important aren't they when you're
discussing the the nuclear threat
they are and one of the running themes
throughout uh throughout this entire
crisis has been Vlad uh sorry Emmanuel
macron attempting to uh present himself
attempting to act as a go-between
between Vladimir Putin uh Emmanuel uh
Vladimir zelensky and the west and it's
not already worked as everybody can see
full well uh the the reason why this has
kept up such a fuss is uh Emmanuel
macron has said very explicitly that
France's nuclear weapons would not be
used uh in the conflict with Russia he
said that they wouldn't be used in a
manner that would be counter to the
interests of the French nation and in
doing so he has slightly betrayed his
hand that's what Ben Wallace is saying
is that he's saying very explicitly know
that we won't use on nuclear weapons and
that that for therefore gives Vladimir
Putin uh some sort of incentive to
ratchet up the tension in Ukraine and
potentially to use nuclear weapons
himself if he believes that NATO Nations
wouldn't be prepared to uh retaliate in
kind now let's be very clear here
Ukraine is not a member of NATO there is
you know sort of reciprocity there and I
don't believe actually that NATO nations
would use nuclear weapons were the
Russians to deploy them in Ukraine but I
do think that there would be a change in
the nature of the conflicts it would
provoke a military response from NATO
Nations uh targeting key Russian
military infrastructure and so you can
understand I think therefore why NATO
the US the UK would be irritated with
Emmanuel macron because they don't want
to be getting into a sort of a tip for
town of saying what they will and won't
do what Their red lines are and are not
because of course we saw that in Syria
with President Obama saying exactly what
his red lines would be on the use of
chemical weapons they were then crossed
and nothing was done in response and I
think that that is the Trap that NATO
don't want to fall into on this occasion
yeah I mean the nuclear deterrent works
until it doesn't it it tends to be the
case doesn't it do you think macron has
overstepped the Mark here made a mistake
Leslie
well it's a strange one because it seems
in as part of that uh that interview
that he had with French TV and he
started off saying that the less was
said in in public the better and then
went on to clarify this point about uh
just absolutely not using the French
nuclear deterrent um if there was uh to
be a strike by Russia but there seems to
be speculation that France is trying to
kind of push for a different overall
policy within Europe to be more
autonomous from the United States and
the thinking is that that those comments
will again have left most of his allies
uh the rest of the EU
looking at this and thinking well if
that's not the kind of leadership that
you want from France then once again
that seems to make everyone feel they
have to rely on the United States again
so it's a complex thing it seems to have
walked into the middle of I kind of
wonder whether he really intended to go
that far or not and it seems that other
politicians in France have been quite
shocked by the outspokenness of the
comments yeah um we've just got about 20
seconds to to talk about this final
story Benedict we'll do it more about
perhaps in the next hour but gay
football fans will be safe to show each
other affection at qatar's World Cup uh
its Chief organizer has been speaking
exclusively to Sky News the Metro
covering it
this was always going to be an issue
when it came to a World Cup in a part of
the world where homosexuality is illegal
and where there are a lot of very severe
cultural issues around it I mean it's
one thing for authorities in a place
like Qatar to say that fans will be free
and won't be discriminated against by
the authorities but actually I think the
key thing that is mentioned in the story
here is that he says that he would like
fans to be respectful of the culture
that they walk into and I think that's
the key thing it may well be that the
authorities the police do not uh show
sort of nastiness or Crackdown on fans
but the response that they get from
locals might be very different and I
think that that's something that needs
to be born in mind okay uh thank you
both and we'll speak again uh very
shortly right now we're going to take a
quick look at the weather